this i think was the story of the week
uh playboy for the first time
uh had a gay mail
cover
take a look here we go we're gonna show
you a little video they even put a
little they made it move for video
purposes so there's some guy on playboy
he's dressed up like a playboy playmate
there you go zippity doodah
um
chad i assume a lot of guys that
subscribe to playboy i'm not sure how
many people do at this point uh they
must
you know be pretty excited about that
right because that shows that they're
more diverse and open-minded and things
of that nature
listen i'm a red-blooded american male
i'm very visually oriented and i always
read playboy for the pictures
i don't know who they were targeting uh
in this i don't know what demographic
they were going after i mean this is
like out magazine putting a a
heterosexual
i mean what's the point it doesn't make
any sense what are you trying to promote
here it doesn't make any sense to me but
this is a perfect situation of you just
you're being woke for the sake of being
woke and so in my book when i ask am i
crazy this is a perfect example the
world has gone crazy
libby is this like the perfect example
also of how woke destroys everything
like like not one person there is
literally not one person on planet earth
who wasn't subscribing to playboy that's
now going to subscribe because of that
however there are people probably that
subscribe to playboy that are just going
to say this isn't my thing
not because they're homophobes but that
wasn't what they were subscribing to
woke destroys everything
yeah no i agree with a lot of what chad
said but i also would like to say to the
men of the world if you want to step up
and be on
cover magazines and you know be
objectified like all the pretty headed
little ladies before you by whole means
strut your stuff go for it take the
place that so many women have been in
before uh you know go for it objectify
the hell out of yourself and um
nobody really subscribes to playboy
anyway i think they stopped printing
didn't they did they even exist
i just remember a stack of
playboys
there was a stack of playboys in my
uncle sids foyer when i was a kid and my
cousins and i had a field day with them
you know it's an interesting question i
asked my producers when we talked about
this the other day and nobody knows that
they're even still in print that's right
you guys are telling me they did it
that's why they did it my guys are
telling me they're not imprinted anymore
yeah it was just maybe that's what it
was a marketing scheme so that people
would notice they exist rob you're
getting the final word i assume you will
be subscribing to the digital edition of
playboy am i correct
after looking at that photo i'm going to
convert i'm no longer sexual that that
photo is so sexy and so
provocative that i will be subscribing
now
um but but you know what i i feel like
they're not even targeting like ordinary
like gay people i feel like this is like
a target towards like very
woke gen z
you know gauge you know
queer non-binary type of people with the
kind of display
that they have and so like that's what
happens right you have you know people
at the new york times people at
reputable institutions and playboy and
college universities who are young who
are woke gen z who have all these
radical ideas and they just want to
destroy everything reconstruct beauty
standards aesthetics language and
everything and so you see all this woke
rot everywhere and i will make sure i
subscribe to playboy
right away after we get after this call
i can't believe it someone actually is
gonna subscribe to playboy after this
thing